Bonjour! Une fois n'est pas coutume, j'ai
décidé de commencer l'année par un épisode
historiographique. C'est à dire un épisode
qui parlera de l'histoire de l'histoire, pourquoi
on étudie tel sujet, et comment, et quelles
connaissances on en tire... Bref, la discipline
historique a bieeeen évolué depuis le XIXe
siècle.
-Dont on avait un peu parlé dans l'épisode
sur le Roman National, tout au début de la
chaîne.
-Il y a quelques temps je vous avais aussi
parlé de microhistoire à travers le livre
«Le Plancher de Joachim», et j'avais
trouvé ça passionnant. Et j'espère que
vous aussi. L'historiographie est un sujet
assez peu connu du grand public, on bachote
plutôt ça quand on est en études d'histoire
soi-même, donc il me semblait intéressant
de vous en parler de temps en temps.
Du coup, aujourd'hui on va parler de l'histoire
des femmes, sujet ô combien important sur
bien des plans.
-Cet épisode est dédié à tous ceux qui
nous trouvent trop féministes, dans les commentaires.
Abonnez-vous.
Et pour commencer, pourquoi faire l'histoire
des femmes? Jusqu'à ce qu'on s'intéresse
à ce sujet, l'histoire est présentée comme
générale, considérée comme universelle,
c'est l'histoire de l'homme avec un grand
H. Non, pas comme ça Aliénor.
La différence des sexes n'est pas prise en
compte dans les discours mais occulte dans
les faits 50% de la population, mis à part
quelques femmes illustres comme Jeanne d'Arc
ou Cléopâtre. On retrouve cette invisibilisation
dans de nombreux sujets, comme l'histoire
du droit de vote par exemple: des tas d'ouvrages
narrent la conquête du suffrage universel
en 1848, alors qu'il ne devient vraiment universel
qu'en 1944.
Cela peut s'expliquer par le fait que l'histoire
universitaire reste très longtemps une affaire
d'hommes, écrite par des hommes, mais on
reviendra sur cette évolution plus tard.
L'invisibilité des femmes dans l'histoire
est résumée par Virginia Woolf dans son
ouvrage Une chambre à soi, paru en 1929:
«Je m’adressai à nouveau au Pr Trevelyan
pour savoir quelle était sa conception de
l’Histoire. J’ai trouvé, en regardant
les têtes de chapitre, qu’il la comprenait
ainsi : « La cour du château et les méthodes
de culture en plein champ… Les cisterciens
et l’élevage des moutons… Les croisades…
L’université… La Chambre des Communes…
La guerre de Cent Ans… La guerre des Deux
Roses… Les érudits de la Renaissance…
La dissolution des monastères… Le conflit
agraire et religieux… L’origine de la
puissance maritime de l’Angleterre… La
grande Armada, etc. » De temps en temps,
une femme précise est mentionnée, une Élisabeth
ou une Marie Stuart ; une reine ou une grande
dame. Mais jamais une femme de la classe moyenne,
n’ayant à sa disposition que son intelligence
et son caractère, n’a pu participer à
l’un quelconque des grands mouvements qui,
rapprochés, constituent la vue de l’historien
sur le passé. Et nous ne trouverons pas non
plus la femme dans les collections d’anecdotes
d’Aubrey. Jamais elles n’écrivaient leurs
mémoires, rarement elles tinrent un journal,
on ne possède d’elles qu’une poignée
de lettres. Elles ne laissèrent ni drames,
ni poèmes sur lesquels nous puissions les
juger. Ce dont on a besoin, pensais-je, c’est
une masse de renseignements, et pourquoi quelque
brillant étudiant de Newnham ou de Girton
ne nous la procurerait-il pas ? À quel âge
se mariaient-elles ? À quoi ressemblaient
leurs maisons ? Disposaient-elles d’une
chambre à elles ? Faisaient-elles la cuisine
? Pouvaient-elles avoir une domestique ? Toutes
ces précisions se trouvent quelque part,
dans les registres communaux et les livres
de comptes, sans doute. La vie de la femme
moyenne sous le règne d’Élisabeth doit
être dispersée en de multiples endroits.
Ne pourrait-on pas rassembler ces éléments
épars et en faire un livre ? C’est là
une ambition qui dépasse mon audace, pensai-je,
tout en cherchant sur les rayons des livres
qui ne s’y trouvaient pas, que de suggérer
aux étudiants de ces fameuses facultés de
réécrire l’Histoire. Il me semble pourtant
bien reconnaître que l’Histoire telle qu’elle
est me semble un peu bizarre, irréelle et
bâtie de guingois. Mais pourquoi n’ajouterait-on
pas un supplément à l’Histoire ? Supplément
auquel on donnerait, bien entendu, un nom
sans importance pour que les femmes puissent
y figurer sans inconvenance ? […] Me voici
en train de me demander pourquoi, à l’époque
élisabéthaine, les femmes n’écrivaient
pas de poésie et je ne suis pas seulement
sûre de la façon dont elles étaient élevées.
Leur apprenait-on à écrire ? Avaient-elles
un salon personnel ? Combien de femmes avaient-elles
des enfants avant leur vingt et unième année
? En un mot que faisaient-elles de huit heures
du matin à huit heures du soir ?»
La volonté première des historiennes de
l'histoire des femmes est donc de faire sortir
les femmes de l'oubli, de montrer qu'elles
ont aussi une histoire souvent différente
de celle des hommes et complémentaire, et
qu'on ne peut considérer l'histoire comme
universelle sans s'intéresser aussi aux femmes.
-Ça paraît pourtant évident, dit comme
ça, mais ce n'est pas gagné.
-Cette volonté émerge en même temps que
le courant historique de la «nouvelle histoire»,
dans les années 1960, qui découle en partie
de la décolonisation et s'intéresse particulièrement
aux marginaux, aux groupes minoritaires ou
opprimés, aux exclus. Tout comme eux les
femmes constituent une minorité sociale et
politique, or l'histoire reste longtemps celle
de la majorité sociale et politique, des
groupes dirigeants.
-Le philosophe Michel Foucault, par exemple,
encourage la lecture de la société à partir
de ses exclus. Aliénor, tu vois, on peut
parler de toi.
-Gnagna. L'autre mouvement qui lance définitivement
l'histoire des femmes est le féminisme, évidemment.
Dans les années d'après-guerre le décalage
entre l'histoire et la société, en France,
est de plus en plus flagrant, après l'acquisition
du droit de vote, la création du Planning
Familial, la démocratisation de l'enseignement
supérieur pour les femmes... La création
du MLF en 1970 est signifiante, notamment
la manifestation du 26 août 1970 devant l'Arc
de Triomphe. Parmi les banderoles déployées,
on lit: «Il y a plus inconnu que le soldat
inconnu: sa femme.»
Du coup, l'histoire des femmes découle d'une
impulsion aussi bien militante que scientifique.
La première décennie de l'histoire des femmes
produit des travaux engagés sur les mécanismes
de la domination masculine, sur la victimisation
des femmes au cours de l'histoire ou sur leurs
révoltes... L'historienne Françoise Thébaud
parle d' «Histoire du malheur».
-Ces travaux sont principalement écrits par
des femmes, engagées, il existe donc une
complicité quasi inédite entre le sujet
et son autrice.
-De manière générale, il existe toujours
un rapport entre un historien ou une historienne
et le sujet choisi, conscient, affirmé ou
non. Mais c'est la première fois que cette
proximité est autant revendiquée. L'histoire
des femmes est le premier champ historique
à être autant lié à un mouvement social,
avec l'histoire ouvrière certes. Ses enjeux
sont de légitimer l'existence du féminisme,
en faisant valoir le passé des femmes, et
de justifier les revendications de l'époque.
Cette nouvelle histoire connaît des résistances
bien sûr: Laura Lee Downs, qui enseigne
l'histoire des femmes en 1989 aux États-Unis,
témoigne de l'exaspération d'une partie
de ses étudiants chaque fois qu'elle aborde
le sujet, convaincus que ces détours vers
l'histoire des femmes les privent d'une partie
de la «vraie» histoire.
Rebecca Rogers raconte, dans les années 90,
que certains de ses élèves écrivent en
bas de leurs évaluations « je ne sais pas
pourquoi on est obligé d’écouter cette
féministe marxiste ».
-C'est l'unfollow.
-En France, Françoise Thébaud perçoit surtout
de l'étonnement de la part de ses élèves,
qui lui reprochent de sortir de la discipline
historique.
Michelle Perrot, pionnière de l'histoire
des femmes en France, écrit dans un de ses
premiers ouvrages: «femmes emmurées,
comment vous rejoindre?»
En effet, écrire l'histoire des femmes nécessite
de repenser totalement les sources sur lesquelles
s'appuient les historiens habituellement.
Longtemps exclues de la sphère publique,
les femmes n'ont pas laissé de traces dans
les archives diplomatiques, administratives,
dans la presse... Et quand elles en ont laissé,
ces documents ont parfois été détruits
ou mal catalogués, la conservation des archives
n'étant pas neutre. Dans le cadre de la Commune
de Paris par exemple, les dossiers judiciaires
des hommes ont été beaucoup mieux conservés
que ceux des femmes bien que seuls 15 000
dossiers de communards survivent sur un total
d'environ 40 000. Les dossiers de non-lieu
ont tous été détruits en 1936, par un archiviste
qui les jugeait inutiles. Concernant les femmes,
les dossiers ont simplement disparu, sauf
celui de Louise Michel. En 1964, dans le Procès
de Communards de Jacques Rougerie, l'auteur
ne consacre qu'une poignée de pages aux communardes,
juste avant la partie sur les enfants, expliquant
qu'elles étaient trop peu nombreuses pour
faire l'objet de la même analyse que les
hommes.
-On sait maintenant que c'est très loin de
la réalité.
-En 1982, à force de travail à la bibliothèque
historique de la ville de Paris, l'historienne
Maïté Albistur rassemble des milliers de
documents sur l'histoire des femmes qui n'avaient
jamais été inventoriés.
En travaillant sur les archives, les historiennes
de l'histoire des femmes doivent poser un
regard nouveau sur les documents à leur disposition.
Elles constatent alors que les sources ne
sont pas aussi muettes que ça: les archives
policières et judiciaires parlent et font
parler les femmes. Anne-Marie Sohn se sert
de ces sources en 1996 dans sa thèse sur
les rôles féminins dans la vie privée,
par exemple.
La plupart des sources peuvent aussi être
lues «en creux» et faire alors surgir
le regard porté sur les femmes. Laura Lee
Dows, qui travaille sur les femmes ouvrières,
explique ainsi qu'elle les a longtemps crues
non qualifiées pour la simple raison qu'elles
étaient toutes rassemblées au même endroit
dans les archives tandis que les hommes étaient
divisés entre «qualifiés», «semi-qualifiés»
et «non-qualifiés». Il se trouve qu'en
fait ces femmes étaient pour la plupart qualifiées.
Joan Kelly, spécialiste de la Renaissance,
raconte que lorsqu'elle est sollicitée en
1971 pour participer à un cours sur l'histoire
des femmes elle répond d'abord qu'elle n'a
rien à dire. Puis après quelques jours de
réflexion et de reconsidération des livres
et des documents à sa disposition, elle se
rend compte que l'histoire qu'elle donne de
la Renaissance est déformée et incomplète
et développe un cours «Les femmes ont-elles
connu une Renaissance?».
L'histoire des femmes, tout comme l'histoire
culturelle à la même période, contribue
ainsi à élargir la notion de sources. Elle
s'appuie aussi sur la presse, les correspondances,
les livres de comptes, les papiers personnels,
les journaux intimes, qui sont de moins en
moins rares à partir du XIXe siècle. Ces
archives familiales et «archives de soi»
mettent du temps à s'imposer mais sont maintenant
reconnues comme des sources utiles à la recherche
historique, même si jusqu'au début du XXe
siècle elles ne sont le fruit que de milieux
aisés ou militants.
D'autres historiens s'intéressent à l'image
des femmes, dans la symbolique religieuse
ou républicaine. L'histoire des représentations
est utile à l'histoire des femmes, Mathilde
Dubesset s'appuie par exemple dans ses recherches
sur les photographies d'ouvrières et d'employées
de Saint-Etienne dans la première moitié
du XXe siècle pour révéler les normes posturales
de chaque sexe et la valeur attribuée aux
tâches des uns et des autres.
-L'histoire du temps présent s'appuie aussi
sur le cinéma et les sources audiovisuelles,
depuis les années 1990.
-Enfin, il y a l'histoire orale, qui émerge
dans les années 1960 en même temps que l'histoire
des femmes. Le recours aux témoignages se
développe d'abord en Grande-Bretagne et en
Italie, permettant de faire surgir une histoire
populaire construite à partir du point de
vue de ceux et celles qui sont dominés. Ses
premiers représentants en France sont par
exemple Jacques Ozouf, qui travaille sur les
instituteurs du début du XXe siècle. Les
sources orales permettent de rendre compte
de l'expérience de groupes absents des documents
écrits, mais rencontrent un accueil mitigé.
D'abord, on se questionne sur la pertinence
d'interroger un destin individuel par rapport
à l'analyse de centaines de documents écrits.
L'histoire de mentalité n'en est qu'à ses
débuts. Aussi, on remet en cause la fiabilité
de ces sources orales, basées sur la mémoire
et souvent recueillies longtemps après les
faits évoqués. Les personnes interrogées
sont-elles vraiment capables de se rappeler
fidèlement les événements décrits?
Les psychologues qui ont travaillé sur le
sujet ont démontré que c'est au contraire
dans les jours qui suivent un événement
que la mémoire rejette la plus grande quantité
d'informations, et que les souvenirs se fixent
par la suite. Ils prouvent aussi que la mémoire
des personnes âgées n'est pas moins fiable
que celle des jeunes adultes. Ils remarquent
aussi, cependant, que la mémoire est un mélange
de vécu et d'appris, de vrai et d'imaginaire,
et que certains témoins ont tendance à rapporter
des mythes entourant des grands événements
comme s'ils les avaient vécus ou à raconter
des événements en réalité vécus par leurs
parents. Le souvenir joue un grand rôle aussi:
on a plus tendance à se rappeler d'un événement
public s'il est lié à quelque chose de personnel,
la date d'un mariage par exemple. Les chercheuses
qui interviewent des femmes remarquent en
effet qu'elles reconstruisent la trame de
leur vie en se référant à la naissance
de leurs enfants, à la mort d'un proche...
et non aux grands événements historiques
sauf s'ils ont perturbé leur quotidien.
-L'assassinat de Montereau? Connais pas.
Est-ce que je vous ai parlé du 10 septembre
1419, quand j'ai cueilli un champignon...
-Cependant, les chercheurs Paul Thompson et
Alessandro Porteli démontrent que l'écrit
n'est pas plus objectif que l'oral. Déjà
parce que les documents écrits ne sont souvent
qu'une transcription de l'oral incluant la
perception des événements qu'en avait l'auteur,
ensuite parce qu'il s'écoule souvent aussi
un laps de temps entre l'événement et sa
mise par écrit.
-Et César vainquit les sauvages gaulois moustachus...
-T'es pas née au Ier siècle, toi?
-Chuuut...
Et puis comme on l'a vu, les documents écrits
ont plus souvent tendance à occulter les
femmes dans l'histoire.
L'histoire des femmes, tout comme l'histoire
culturelle et l'histoire des mentalités,
permet donc un formidable renouveau du rapport
des historiens aux sources à partir des années
1970 qui bénéficie à toute la discipline.
Comme le dit Michelle Perrot en 1975: «L’histoire
des femmes demande de l’ingéniosité pour
pallier la pauvreté des sources classiques
[…]. Les méthodes de cette histoire devraient
emprunter beaucoup à l’ethnologie, aussi
bien pour le déchiffrement des mythologies
que pour l’exploration du quotidien. Comme
elle, elle devrait user de la quête du récit,
à la manière des Anglo-Saxons beaucoup plus
avancés que nous dans cette direction de
l’histoire orale. Enfin l’histoire des
femmes devrait réaffirmer sans cesse sa problématique
qui est la recherche obstinée d’une relation
à l’autre sexe et à l’histoire globale.»
Dans la première partie, même si j'ai commencé
à parler de l'émergence de l'histoire des
femmes dans les années 70, je voulais surtout
vous présenter la raison pour laquelle cette
discipline émerge. Et maintenant, on va voir
plus concrètement comment elle prend vie
et trouve sa place dans les institutions historiques.
On trouve des précurseurs de l'histoire des
femmes avant les années 70. Christine de
Pizan, voire même Emilia Bassano dont je
vous parlais dans le dernier Gentes Dames
Badass célèbrent dans leurs écrits les
grandes dames du passé et revendiquent leur
place dans l'histoire. En 1804, Fortunée
Briquet rédige également le Dictionnaire
historique des Françaises. Les vies de saintes
sont aussi courantes à cette époque.
De manière générale les travaux sur les
femmes au XIXe siècle sont surtout biographiques,
ils peuvent viser à montrer la supériorité
morale des femmes ou à mettre en avant des
personnalités comme Marie Antoinette, sainte
Claire d'Assise... D'autres travaux s'intéressent
déjà à la vie quotidienne et aux mentalités
de certaines populations, dont les femmes.
-C'est le cas des travaux de Lucy Maynard
Salmon par exemple, méprisée par la profession
qui qualifie ses recherches d' «histoire
d'arrière cour».
-Les différents courants d'histoire qui se
succèdent depuis le XIXe siècle, l'école
méthodiste, les Annales, l'histoire quantitative,
excluent les femmes et les dimensions sexuelles
de leurs champs de recherche. Pire encore,
ils invisibilisent le travail de certaines
historiennes.
Simone Vidal Bloch, épouse de Marc Bloch,
n'est jamais mentionnée dans les travaux
de son mari bien qu'elle l'aide dans ses recherches
et ses relectures de manuscrits. Suzanne Febvre,
agrégée d'histoire, arrête son doctorat
dès son mariage pour élever ses enfants
et assister son mari, qui devient l'un des
historiens les plus connus du XXe siècle.
Lucien Febvre prend également comme assistante
Lucie Varga, docteure en histoire du Moyen
Âge et bonne observatrice du nazisme qui
est l'une des deux seules femmes à signer
des articles dans la revue des Annales avant
1944. Mais elle est abandonnée par Febvre,
apparemment à cause de sa passion naissante
pour Lucie, doit abandonner ses recherches
et meurt en 1941, à 36 ans. La deuxième
femme à être publiée dans la revue des
Annales, Thérèse Sclafert, est médiéviste
mais n'a pas de poste universitaire.
-La première thèse soutenue par une femme
remonte à 1923, il s'agit d'un doctorat es
lettres avec spécialisation en histoire soutenu
par Madeleine Deries.
-Qui meurt un an après sa soutenance, et
sombre donc dans l'oubli.
-Les premières thèses sur l'histoire des
femmes remontent aux années 1930 et proviennent
d'hommes et de femmes proches des mouvements
féministes. Edith Thomas, par exemple, rédige
des biographies de femmes révolutionnaires
dans les années 1950.
Aux États-Unis, le développement de l'histoire
des femmes est plus aisé grâce au système
universitaire. Des petites universités pour
femmes existent dès le XIXe siècle, souvent
sur le même campus que les grandes universités
dont elles sont des annexes. De plus le féminisme
n'a pas la même signification aux États-Unis
qu'en France, ou il évoque souvent une position
extrémiste vis-à-vis des hommes, comme les
fameuses féminazies de Twitter. Se dire féministe
aux États-Unis exposant bien moins à toutes
sortes d'idées reçues, on peut comprendre
que ce pays constitue un terreau plus favorable
au développement de l'histoire des femmes
dans les années 60.
À cette époque donc, on ne dénombre que
trois femmes sur 120 professeurs d'histoire
en France. Les mouvements sociaux aux États-Unis
sont suivis en Europe des grèves et mouvements
étudiants de mai 68. Les États-Unis et la
Grande-Bretagne sont donc pionniers en histoire
des femmes, avec le cours «Did women have
a Renaissance» de Joan Kelly en 1972. Les
premiers centres de recherches sur les femmes
sont fondés dans des universités publiques
et privées, le premier étant le Mary Ingraham
Bunting Institute en 1960, au Radcliffe College,
la section féminine de Harvard. Un Institute
for Research on Women and Gender est crée
à Stanford en 1974. Le développement de
ces centres, plus rapide qu'en France, est
permis par le financement privé sur lequel
repose ces universités.
En France, les pionnières de l'histoire des
femmes sont des sociologues, qui s'intéressent
au travail des femmes. Le développement de
cette histoire s'accompagne de l'arrivée
de femmes dans la discipline: quatre femmes
sont nommées professeurs d'histoire contemporaine
en 1970, dont Michelle Perrot qui s'engage
dans ce nouveau courant historique. En 1971
on compte autant de filles que de garçons
reçus à l'agrégation d'histoire, et le
concours devient mixte en 1974.
-Les premiers cours d'histoire des femmes
sont mis en place en 1973, le premier étant
donné par Michelle Perrot et ayant pour titre
«Les femmes ont-elles une histoire?»
-Titre qui montre bien le manque de connaissances
encore criant dans cette discipline.
A ses débuts, l'histoire des femmes utilise
beaucoup le même schéma de la confiscation
du pouvoir des femmes par les hommes, mais
en y apportant nuances et recul. Les historiennes
mettent très tôt en avant la scientificité
de leur démarche.
La reconnaissance par les institutions scientifiques
se fait donc, en douceur. La première revue
d'histoire des femmes, Pénélope, est créée
en 1979 mais disparaît en 1985 faute de soutien
institutionnel.
Dans les années 70, l'histoire reste partagée
entre l'histoire économique et sociale promue
par l'école des Annales et l'histoire «événementielle»,
politique, militaire et diplomatique. Cependant,
de nouveaux courants historiques apparaissent:
l'histoire des corps, de la maladie, des comportements
sexuels, de l'alimentation, de la mort...
À cette époque l'histoire s'ouvre vers d'autres
disciplines, la sociologie et l'anthropologie
par exemple.
-On parle alors de «nouvelle histoire».
Des courants semblables se retrouvent dans
tous les pays: en Italie avec la microhistoire,
dont j'ai déjà parlé dans un épisode,
et en Allemagne avec l'histoire du quotidien
par exemple.
Dans ce contexte, différents champs d'étude
en histoire des femmes émergent. L'un des
premiers est la question du travail des femmes,
du rapport entre femmes et mouvements ouvriers.
Contrairement à ce qu'on pensait auparavant,
l'industrialisation au XIXe siècle ne provoque
pas de rupture pour les femmes, au niveau
travail et famille, mais on constate plutôt
une continuité avec l'ancienne économie
rurale. On constate aussi la méfiance des
mouvements ouvriers français envers le travail
des femmes, craignant la concurrence de ces
travailleuses. Elles sont d'ailleurs assez
peu impliquées dans les révoltes ouvrières.
Bien sûr je ne vais pas pouvoir vous raconter
tous les aspects de tous les champs de recherche
de l'histoire des femmes, le but étant ici
de vous montrer quelques exemples d'études.
Bien sûr, l'histoire des femmes est très
tôt l'histoire des oppressions et des transgressions.
Certaines historiennes s'intéressent ainsi
aux héroïnes, féministes, grévistes du
XIXe siècle qui luttent contre l'ordre établi.
Michelle Perrot résume ces recherches en
1987: « l’histoire des femmes a d’abord
été celle de leur oppression ; femmes battues,
trompées, humiliées, violées, sous-payées,
abandonnées, folles et enfermées…, on
a fait l’inventaire des malheurs féminins,
sans toujours s’interroger sur les mécanismes
de la domination, en en voyant plutôt les
effets ; histoire nécessaire, mais déprimante
aussi ».
Évidemment l'histoire des femmes n'est pas
l'histoire du féminisme, mais le féminisme
fait partie des sujets étudiés.
Le genre biographique, qui a longtemps été
une composante centrale de l'histoire, connaît
aussi un fort renouveau, de nombreux ouvrages
sont rédigés sur des militantes ou intellectuelles
des XIXe et XXe siècles.
-Un peu ce qu'on fait avec les Gentes Dames
Badass!
-On parle de moi?
-La fonction de ces biographies est de montrer
que les femmes sont aussi capables que les
hommes de faire l'histoire, et de reproduire
la définition épique de l'histoire en opposant
aux exploits d'hommes des exploits de femmes.
De plus en plus de thèses d'histoire des
femmes portent sur une ou quelques femmes.
Au-delà de ces révoltes individuelles, d'autres
historiennes s'intéressent aux résistances
diffuses des femmes, à leurs lieux de sociabilité:
le marché, le lavoir, le four, les associations
et congrégations féminines, mais aussi les
participations aux émeutes et aux grèves.
Un autre champ d'étude important est l'histoire
de la famille et de la sexualité, étudié
du point de vue des femmes. C'est le cas d'Angus
McLaren qui étudie l'avortement au XIXe siècle,
par exemple. L'histoire des corps est également
très répandue. L'activité des femmes au
sein de la maison, au moment de l'héritage,
leur activité économique au sein de la famille
constituent de nombreux sujets d'étude à
toutes les périodes.
L'éducation des femmes est également abordée.
En 1976 Françoise Mayeur soutient une thèse
sur l'enseignement secondaire des jeunes filles
au XIXe siècle, de la création des cours
Duruy à l'alignement des enseignements secondaires
masculins et féminins en 1924.
Au-delà de ces champs de recherche, l'histoire
des femmes permet de remettre en cause la
chronologie établie depuis longtemps en histoire.
La succession de règnes et de régimes ou
la division entre Antiquité, Moyen Âge,
époque moderne et époque contemporaine perdent
encore plus de sens si on envisage l'histoire
à partir de l'expérience des femmes. Joan
Kelly conclut son cours sur la Renaissance
en déclarant que les femmes ne l'ont pas
connue, du moins pas dans la période nommée.
Durant la première guerre mondiale, hommes
et femmes vivent deux chronologies du conflit:
départ à la guerre vs attente en 1914, enlisement
dans les tranchées et perte d'espoir vs mise
au travail des femmes dès 1915.
En 1994, Françoise Thébaud interroge la
Libération de 1945 en se demandant si les
femmes ont vraiment bénéficié de la révolution
politique, économique et sociale qui accompagne
cette période. Même si elles y obtiennent
le droit de vote, elles ne peuvent être élues
et ne se «libèrent» socialement qu'à
partir des années 60.
De nos jours l'histoire des femmes s'est encore
élargie, n'hésitant pas par exemple à s'intéresser
aux postures considérées comme négatives
comme la collaboration, la violence exercée
par les femmes.
-À ce titre la violence des femmes a longtemps
été sous-évaluée, beaucoup de femmes étant
acquittée de leurs crimes car considérées
comme mineures, ou encore parce que ces femmes
source de fécondité ne méritaient pas les
même peines que les hommes.
-Certains champs de recherche se sont déplacés:
de l'exploration des femmes dans la sphère
privée, durant les années 70 et 80, on est
passé à une exploration beaucoup plus forte
de la sphère public, de leur accès à la
citoyenneté, de leurs droits politiques...
L'histoire du travail s'est aussi tournée
de l'usine vers d'autres corps de métier,
infirmières, institutrices, enseignantes...
-D'autres champs restent peu étudiés:
l'histoire du travail des femmes dans les
champs, justement, ou dans l'artisanat et
les boutiques.
-D'autres historiens étudient le rapport
au genre dans les territoires, villes et campagnes,
dans la laïcité, la colonisation, les sciences
et savoirs, les identités...
Le développement de l'histoire des femmes
a permis l'émergence de l'histoire du genre,
un terme de plus en plus employé dès les
années 80 dans les universités anglo-saxonnes.
Le genre ou gender désigne le sexe social
et le rapport entre les sexes, thème que
l'histoire des femmes soulève dès le départ.
Il est théorisé à la fin des années 60
par des sociologues et dépend de la construction
sociale, des représentations, des activités
et rôles assignés, des croyances... À la
différence du sexe qui est beaucoup plus
fixe. Joan Scott en propose la définition
suivante: « Le genre est un élément constitutif
des rapports sociaux fondé sur des différences
perçues entre les sexes, et le genre est
une façon première de signifier des rapports
de pouvoir ». Cette notion n'est même pas
récente: certains auteurs de traités de
médecine aux XVIe et XVIIe siècles distinguaient
déjà le sexe, organe de la reproduction,
du genre qui englobait les différences corporelles
et morales.
-En gros, on passe tout simplement d'une histoire
considérée comme universelle mais qui ignorait
les femmes à une histoire des femmes, puis
à une histoire vraiment universelle cette
fois qui tient compte du fait qu'il existe
des hommes et des femmes avec tous les rapports
sociaux que ça implique.
-En France, le terme est peu utilisé en histoire
jusqu'aux années 2000. On préfère longtemps
parler de «rapports de sexe» ou tout
simplement de «sexe», le terme de «genre»
restant largement incompris.
-Les éditeurs ne sont pas très chauds pour
l'utiliser: la table ronde de 1993 sur «le
genre de la protection» est publiée sous
le titre «Différence des sexes et protection
sociale».
-La gender history permet pourtant de reconsidérer
des événements et phénomènes historiques.
L'histoire du travail ouvrier féminin, par
exemple, est ainsi progressivement remplacée
par une histoire sexuée du travail ouvrier,
qui montre la manière dont la différence
sexuelle façonne les relations dans l'entreprise.
-La gender history s'intéresse aussi à des
sujets historiques nouveaux: Sylvie Steinberg
étudie ainsi le travestissement au Moyen
Âge et à l'époque moderne.
-La notion de genre permet aussi de se rendre
compte que si on s'est mis à faire de l'histoire
des femmes, à partir d'une histoire qu'on
considérait comme neutre jusque-là, on peut
aussi faire de l'histoire des hommes.
Les men's studies apparaissent également
à la fin des années 70, étudiant par exemple
la masculinisation de la symbolique ouvrière,
la virilité, la vie et les sentiments des
soldats de la Grande Guerre, la paternité...
-De nos jours l'histoire des femmes est donc
davantage reconnue, et a même fait des émules
avec l'apparition de la gender history. La
parution de L'Histoire des Femmes en Occident,
de Georges Duby et Michele Perrot, en 1990,
est l'un des témoins de cette reconnaissance.
Dans l'introduction, les auteurs rappellent:
« Le titre Histoire des femmes en Occident
est commode, et beau. Mais il faut récuser
l’idée que les femmes seraient en elles-mêmes
un objet d’histoire. C’est leur place,
leur “condition”, leurs rôles et leurs
pouvoirs, leurs formes d’action, leur silence
et leur parole que nous entendons scruter,
la diversité de leurs représentations – déesse,
Madone, Sorcière – que nous voulons saisir
dans leur permanence et leurs changements.»
L'histoire des femmes a essaimé dans d'autres
pays à partir des années 90: la Chine,
le Maghreb, les pays d'Europe de l'Est par
exemple. L'Europe fournit toujours la majorité
des adhérents à la Fédération internationale
pour la recherche en histoire des femmes,
mais celle-ci regroupe désormais l'ensemble
des continents.
L'apparition de revues spécialisées, Clio
en 1995, Genre & Histoire en 2007 pour ne
citer que quelques revues françaises, montre
aussi l'intérêt grandissant pour ce champ
de recherche. Les pays anglo-saxons ont là
encore une longueur d'avance: en 1993 la
bibliothèque de l'université du Wisconsin
recense 114 revues consacrées aux women's
studies, dont beaucoup sont consacrées à
l'histoire.
Pour désigner l'histoire des femmes, les
anglophones créent même dans les années
80 le néologisme «herstory», difficilement
traduisible en français. Ce sont aussi les
anglophones qui popularisent la métaphore
de la visibilité, et donc de l'invisibilité
des femmes en histoire jusqu'aux années 70.
Enfin, le dynamisme de l'histoire des femmes
dans ces pays s'explique par le fait que les
historiennes anglophones ont pu créer de
nouvelles institutions dédiées à ces sujets,
tandis que les historiennes françaises ont
plutôt cherché à entrer dans les institutions
déjà existantes et souvent réticentes.
L'institut Émilie du Châtelet, qui vise
à développer et diffuser les recherches
sur les femmes, le sexe et le genre, n'est
crée qu'en 2006, trente ans après le début
de l'histoire des femmes en France.
Depuis les années 2000 les associations se
développent cependant, comme Mnémosyne qui
organise colloques et journées d'études.
La présence de femmes dans les métiers de
l'histoire a également évolué: 41% des
maîtres de conférence et 27M des professeurs
sont des femmes, bien qu'elles soient moins
présentes en histoire moderne et contemporaine.
Des disparités existent toujours, bien sûr,
le choix entre faire des enfants ou avoir
une carrière se pose toujours davantage pour
les femmes que pour les hommes et les logiques
relationnelles au sein des institutions d'histoire
maintiennent des inégalités en faveur des
hommes. Des historiennes comme Arlette Farge
ou Michelle Perrot sont désormais des grands
noms de l'histoire en France, mais ont du
se battre dans les années 80 pour imposer
leur champ de recherche et leur légitimité.
Elles ont été aidées par le grand public,
aussi, qui montre de plus en plus d'intérêt
pour les études de genre. Donc merci à vous.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo dont j'ai
hâte de lire les commentaires.
-C'est de l'ironie.
-J'espère que cette approche historiographique
du sujet vous a intéressés, c'était beaucoup
de travail pour synthétiser tout ça. Comme
d'habitude vous pouvez vous abonner, mettre
des pouces en l'air, partager, et contribuer
au financement de mes vidéos sur Tipeee ou
Utip, les liens sont dans la description ainsi
que la bibliographie nécessaire à la rédaction
de ceci.
Je vous retrouve le mois prochain pour un
Gentes Dames Badass, et la fois suivante pour
du Chroniques de Prof à nouveau, vous connaissez
la routine. Alors portez-vous bien et à bientôt!